[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
simi ol et signoret bonasera ladies and
gentleman good evening mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir
nous sommes ici ce soir pour fêter le
70e anniversaire du festival de cannes
soixante dix ans alors que la beauté
n'est pas lié la jeunesse mais à l'âme
on peut dire que le festival de cannes
est comme une femme dont l'âge et qui
avance ne peut que faire grandir sa
force créatrice en parlant de féminité
créatrice je pense à lui ce bourgeois
qui dit qu'elle a est une garantie de
santé mentale et on part d'une femme
pour qui la maturité est à la base de
ses plus belles créations artistiques
ont fait considérer alors qu'anne comme
les fruits d'une scène folie quand tous
les artistes ayant la faculté de
maintenir en vie la voix de l'enfant qui
est en eux ici toutes les voies peuvent
être écoutées des voix qui viennent de
tous les pays sans exception parce que
le langage du cinéma n'appartient à
aucun territoire et lettres même temps
tous les territoires
c'est la musique et la mathématique sont
des langages et que la même force et
c'est une force capable dé provoquer les
déstabiliser ducret les dialogues
d'émouvoir d'amuser et les sublimes et
aussi tout cela s'appelle la vie et la
vie n'a que nous voulons avec différence
énergie qui se croisent incessamment et
comme la vie le cinéma puise sa source
dans le mélange des forces
complémentaires et contradictoires c'est
pour ça que l'identité du cinéma lundi
sex lies drapeau une frontière mais nef
pays sera présenté en compétition
néanmoins je ne peux pas cacher ma joie
ainsi ligne ans que cette année à cannes
douze films réalisés par des femmes sont
présents que lé président du jury
l homme qui aime les femmes il est super
drôle modo var et puis l'image qui
représente les festivals est incarnée
par claudia cardinale
[Applaudissements]
on est tous des stars on est tous des
étoiles chacun sa manière mais il ya des
étoiles qu'on empêche les briller et
qu'on empêche de s'exprimer
le festival de cannes donne à chaque
étoile la possibilité de retrouver
là-bas la parole et la lumière qu'elle
mérite bonne lumière à vous tous
[Applaudissements]